peu
[Musique]
qui n'a jamais rêvé de se glisser dans
l'intimité d'un écrivain net une petite
souris au mieux une caméra vidéo
frédéric beigbeder a décidé de jouer le
jeu pour nous dans ce journal intime il
traite de ses thèmes de prédilection qui
sont on les connaît la fin du monde
le succès l'insatisfaction son frigo
ces médicaments est lui bien sûr
toujours lui des thèmes que l'on
retrouve dans son dernier roman paru
chez grasset l'égoïste romantique ou
oscar dufresne et le héros et beigbeder
le narrateur à moins que ce ne soit à
linverse avec frédéric on ne sait jamais
mais vous allez voir dans ce journal
intime
frédéric est touchant et c'est un sacré
généreux c'est égoïste
là on est chez moi je suis frédéric
beigbeder à n'ont en pas lui alors alors
ça c'est tout le sujet de mon dernier
livre l'égoïste romantique chez comment
échapper à frédéric bébé j'ai trouvé une
solution
le roman c'est vachement pratique le
roman parce qu'on est libre on peut dire
des trucs qu'on a vraiment fait des
trucs qu'on n'a pas vraiment fait des
trucs qui nous ressemblent des trucs qui
nous ressemblent pas mais qu'on pense
encore plus que les trucs pensé par
celui qui nous ressemble enfin bref ça a
été inventé pour ça la technique
consiste simplement à écrire son journal
en changeant le nom principal le côté
julien gracq et un proche d'eux
nature quand quand je suis attaqué
critiquer j'ai l'impression que c'est
que c'est la personne qui dit ça qui a
raison du personnel si on me dit que mon
livre est mauvais que mon livre est
mauvais que la personne a raison qui que
ce soit il faut que j'arrête tout
thoune a tout ce que j'ai fait depuis
toujours n'a aucun intérêt que je n'ai
aucun intérêt
voilà ça c'est ma chambre je n'ai plus
du tout du tout dit privé à partir de
cette émission ce que je fais c'est
quand j'ai du mal à m'endormir le soir
je prends des manuscrits
c'est un avantage d'être éditeur on peut
assez rapidement avoir sommeil c'est un
métier très chiant puis comme tous les
métiers que j'ai fait mais qui a
davantage de de créer de vraies
rencontres
je progresse dans la mesure où j'ai
l'impression d'avoir une qualité de
rencontres humaines supérieur est ce que
ça pouvait être ya encore trois quatre
ans j'essaie d'aller au musée rodin plus
souvent au lieu d'aller chez castel
alors ça c'est vraiment ordinateur où
j'écris
romantique c'est une chanson donc je
cite dans l'île x10 end of the world as
i feel fine une chanson du groupe verts
au m
et je pense que c'est un des meilleurs
slogans de
actuel tu vois c'est la fin du monde et
le sang khadir
c'est l'apocalypse
nous sommes en train de s'autodétruire
chanteur explique ça et qu'ils sont très
très bien
c'est ça résume assez bien
moment là que
j'ai une vie qui effectivement
correspond à sa main
critère réussi sociale voilà voilà au
matériel ça me rend pas heureux
ouais je trouve ça plus intéressant que
quelqu'un qui dirait c'est génial j'ai
grosses voitures jamais la partie c'est
magnifique
non moi je pense que on peut être
compliqué torturé bizarre dire un truc à
faire l'un vers fait un truc à dire
linverse et faire ça toute sa vie
je pense que ça pose aucun problème et
c'est le grand confort d'être un
romancier c'est de pouvoir justement
être totalement incohérent absurde de se
plaindre dans des boîtes de nuit de luxe
des boîtes de nuit de luxe
ça c'est la liste des médicaments pêche
pour survivre l'impression de près de
préférer la petite musique la grâce la
de mystère le charme plutôt de chekhov
le dolce toy plutôt plutôt fédéral que
anywhere et puis en france
ouais je sais pas plus de cinq ans que
proust un frigo il y avait plein de
produits il ya un peu de tout laisser
c'est que ça c'est bien
évidemment southadé glamourise un peu le
personnage mais ton papa
allez ciao
[Musique]